Canada and so on uh that they will stand
up and work for justice against those
things that are at variance with basic
Notions of human rights which of those
that are as you describe as a variance
um which of those are the ones that
really concern you most well there's the
institutionalized mistreatment of women
uh there is uh the the uh sanction for
wife beating the honor killings genital
mutilation the uh freedom of conscience
the denial of that otherly the death
penalty for those who wish to exercise
their freedom of conscience by leaving
Islam uh the thing is is that of course
it's rare to find Muslim preachers in uh
Western countries speaking openly about
wanting to bring those elements here but
there are efforts to normalize Sharia
and to establish as there already are
quite a few in Great Britain Sharia
arbitration courts and they were the
British public was assured at the time
that those were established that they
would only deal with M matters like
marriage and uh civil matters between
private individuals inheritance and that
kind of thing and not with things that
overlapped with British criminal law but
that was almost immediately contravened
Robert can I ask you um uh how long in a
I can't expect you to know or how where
we sit there about 2% of the population
um identified as Islamic how long do you
think it would be before these values
that you've described um Can infiltrate
our broad Community things can happen
quickly it doesn't have to do with 2% of
the population remember that Lenin and
the bics were a tiny minority who never
won an election in Russia never had a
majority in the Russian Parliament and
yet they were able to overwhelm the
larger population and to create the
Soviet Union because they were focused
they were energ ized they had an
ideology and the greater public was
unaware of what their agenda was and so
this same thing could happen with people
with an authoritarian agenda coming into
uh a country already being there and
imposing that authoritarian agenda upon
the rest of the population while the
media abets them with a campaign of
disinformation that makes people unaware
of what's really happening so how long
could it time well it could take uh well
there's no no telling how long it could
take really because things can happen
very quickly you look for example at
Egypt and uh with Mubarak power for 30
years and people thought I remember uh
that's the year before Mubarak was
toppled from power that there was quite
a bit of speculation that he was now 80
years old and that his son Jamal was
going to take over and everyone
anticipated a peaceful transition nobody
expected that there would be this huge
Arab Spring Uprising and the turmoil
that we've seen since then so really
it's impossible to quantify sure okay we
to put a time frame on it let me put a
time frame on it and you paint a picture
of um and you see Australia could
potentially be if the moons line up
against us in say two years time well
two years time is you know that's uh
it's likely that the tendencies that we
see now will just be accelerating that
there will be more and more
accommodation for Islamic supremacist
demands uh as Pamela was noting that
there have been in workplaces in schools
and elsewhere similar institutions
attempts to uh establish special
accommodation for Islamic law and
practices and to reinforce the principle
that wherever Islamic law and practice
and Western Law and practice conflict
it's Western law that has to give way
and that is something that is uh going
on I think with most people not even
being aware of it as an agenda and
that's going to continue and what of do
you do you accept this notion that
potentially having an organization and
and a brains trust and a and a um
exchange of ideas um that he's seen as
anti-islamic can put Islamic members of
the community well-intentioned moderate
people um no well-intentioned moderate
people should be here with us right now
standing with us for justice and for
freedom and for human rights
well-intentioned sincere moderate people
ought to say oh well we reject all that
as well we don't want to see uh women
beaten and and subjected to
commodification by polygamy and uh honor
killing and and all this business we
don't want to see people executed for
deciding to convert from Islam to
Christianity we reject all that as well
so we'll stand with the c asde but see
it's people like you who make that
impossible because you perpetuate this
myth that to talk about these things is
somehow putting these moderates at risk
when actually they ought to be the ones
standing up most forcefully and vocally
in defense of exactly the same things
that we are standing in defense of
well I actually have I've asked to um
had a deite with you about it and I
you've rejected it because you wanted
money that was actually not the case
what happened was that we agreed to a
debate and they were not moderate group
they're a group that's connected with
his but top rear which is explicitly
dedicated to imposing Islamic law over
Australia and the world and what
happened was is that they had told us
that it would be a free event but then
they were charging
$25 uh uh ahead to have people come in
so we dropped out rather than allow them
to profiter on our name so because you
wouldn't get a clip you wouldn't you
wouldn't talk I'm sorry you wouldn't get
a clip off the off the money you refused
to talk no we we agreed to a free event
we agreed to an event where we were not
going to be paid and they were not going
to be paid then when we found out they
were profiteering we dropped out so I
didn't disclose that to you that was how
we found that out from the announcements
of the event okay and um in terms of
there's been a criticism of you that um
you ignored the the quran's condemnation
of warfare um in the past do you you
accept that can you tell me where this
condemnation of warfare is in the Quran
please that was uh a criticism that's
been
made I haven't read the Quran well I've
I've written the commentary on the
entire Quran and discussed every verse
in it and so it's factually false that
I've actually ignored any verse of the
Quran you can find something that I've
said about every last passage in the
Quran I've also written a book a guide
to the Quran and so to to claim that
I've ignored any part of the Quran is
factually false and I can show you where
I have discussed every last passage of
the Quran but in reality the Quran does
not condemn Warfare in any way shape or
form it says in chapter 9:29 fight
against those who do not obey Allah and
his messenger and do not forbid what he
has forbidden even if they are of the
people of the book which is the quran's
designation primarily for Jews and
Christians until they pay the gizia
which is a tax with willing sub sub
Mission and feel themselves subdued that
is in other words fight the Jews and the
Christians until they submit and are
subjugated under the rule of Islamic law
this is in the quran's ninth chapter
which is the next to last chapter
According to Islamic tradition to have
been revealed to Muhammad and the
chronology is very important because in
the in in standard mainstream Islamic
theology the later passages take
precedence over the earlier ones so you
do find in chapter 109 of the Quran that
it says say uh say to the unbelievers I
do not worship what you worship and you
do not worship what I worship and I'm
not going to worship what you worship
and you're not going to worship what
what I worship you have your religion
and I have mine that's the whole of
chapter 109 in the Quran it's
essentially tolerance it doesn't say
don't go to war but it does say you have
your religion and I have mine and you
know we'll leave each other alone the
problem is is that that's an early
passage and the one counseling Warfare
in joining Warfare for the point of
purpose of subjugation that's a very
late Passage message so it takes
precedence over the earlier it's not
Robert Spencer making this up this is
mainstream Islamic theology based on the
principle the doctrine of agregation
which is in chapter 2 verse 106 of the
Quran which says whenever we cancel a
verse or cause it to be forgotten then
we replace it with one similar or
Superior to it so the later supersedes
the earlier now there's also chap I got
to tell you one more chapter
8:39 fight until religion is all for
Allah so fight until religion is all for
Allah then the Warfare is essentially
ongoing until Islam really Reigns
Supreme Okay I accept you given this a
bit of thought and than you clarify
there is no uh Quran
condemnation I would ask any any uh uh
Muslim of whatever uh stripe whatever
Branch whatever division whatever sect
whatever grouping to come up with such a
verse and show me that it has been
understood In classical commentaries as
forbidding Warfare and I will admit it
that it is not so but there is no such
ver Point very so thank you for that
very much um final question um do you
believe this notion that um that Muslims
believe they are better people than
non-muslims uh you can't say Muslims
believe about anything unless except
it's unless you're saying Muslims
believe that there is no God but Allah
and Muhammad is his messenger because
that's what makes you a Muslim otherwise
Muslims believe any any which any number
of things PE human beings are the same
everywhere Human Nature is the same
everywhere and so people are religious
some people are very religious some
people have all sorts of other
influences and priorities and Muslims
are no different so I have never said
and would never say and I'm not going to
say now Muslims believe X Muslims
believe there's no God but Allah in
muhamad as his messenger but that's it
otherwise you can't generalize I wasn't
suggesting that you said that was just
just a suggestion that's my some that I
was wondering whether you have well the
Quran in chapter 3: 110 says you are the
best of people can we get for all the
Earth and so the Quran tells them that
Superior
okay
um so what do you make of Australia's um
acceptance of
youed
kdom mentioned well I appreciate that
Australia is not yet completely
capitulated to Islamic supremacist
intimidation uh in the way that the UK
has and uh I'm grateful for that and
grateful for the chance that uh the
freedom of speech still lives in
Australia and so we can still have this
discussion uh and it's very difficult of
course to have it in the mainstream
because we're universally demonized and
uh misrepresented in the
main what's that if you're in the United
Kingdom would a conversation this be a
to happen uh well I would hope so uh
certainly I think there are a great many
people of Goodwill in Britain who don't
want to see Britain entirely subjugated
and islamized and uh I hope that they'll
Prevail and that the ban will ultimately
be
overturned
[Music]
problem no I'm not so good at
that okay um are you near for us just to
get a shot of everyone having a bit of a
chat together do you want any more
interview I mean obviously for for one
story
for advertising material describes them
as seasoned civil rights activists
across the weekend Robert Spencer and
Pamela Geller will share their
controversial views and fears on what
they describe as Islam's infiltration of
mainstream Society citing examples in
the United States cashier won't handle
meat that's not Halal if you don't want
to handle meat that's not Halal don't
work at Walmart don't work at Target but
this is how they impose Islam they sue
and they win Robert Spencer says he's
most concerned about the extreme
elements of sharia law sanction for wife
beating the honor killings genital
mutilation the pair was banned from
entering the United Kingdom last year
they intended to lay a wreath in honor
of soldier Lee Rigby who was killed by
Islamic extremists but they say
authorities feared their presence could
cause unrest both campaigners and the Q
Society who helped organize their visit
say their message denounces hatred and
violence there have been 22,000 deadly
Islamic attacks since 9 since 911 each
one with the emperor matter of a Muslim
cleric I think it is a rational fear but
the Islamic Council of Victoria fears
this weekend Symposium which will
involve 14 speakers some from around the
world is based based on fear mongering
and could inight violence their claims
are not made with any context with any
understanding of the religion it's you
know it's guidelines and his teachings
they're just really plucked out for you
know their sensationalist value we worry
that this will increase the likelihood
of such attacks and you know and
violence against Muslims the Symposium
has the support of controversial
right-wing Dutch MP Gert VES who offered
his own online message of support it's a
great achievement for Q society and its
supporters he'll be in Perth next year
for the launch of a new Australian
political party with an anti-islamic
platform founded by some of the Q
Society members they are trying to
impart their laws and live their way in
a western country already both sides of
mainstream Australian politics have
slammed what they describe as the
extremist element Luke Waters SBS world
news